good afternoon everyone this is the uh
second tutorial in the emerging topic
section um on probabilistic
programming so in the next two hours
Frank Wood will introduce us to
probabilistic programming both as a
general concept and in terms of how
current systems work protic programming
is a very truly new emerging uh topic
and it'll shed a light for us on the
historical academic context of it as
well as expose some challenges that are
very unique to probabilistic programming
Frank will also introduce us to anglian
um so there going to be some demos um
anglian is a software system that allows
everyone to write probabilistic programs
so after you leave in two hours you
probably write your first probabilistic
program yourself I personally think the
probalistic programming is one of the
most elegant ways to Define large and
complex probabilistic models and use the
compiler and interpreter technology to
automatically perform model-based
inference I myself had uh made first
experiences and contact with that form
that new form of programming back in
2009 and I actually believe that it do
have the potential to increase the
number of people who can build and
understand their own models um by
several orders of
magnitudes before I hand over to Frank I
uh I'd like to tell you a bit more about
him so Frank is currently an associate
professor in the department of
engineerings um engineering science at
University of Oxford um that's a
position he took in 2013 when he moved
from an assistant professor position at
the statistics group um in Columbia
University for that Frank was a
postdoctoral fellow of the Gatsby
unit um and he uh where he graduated
under supervision of uh u u and he
received this PhD from Brown University
in computer science um under under the
supervision of Michael Black and Tom
Griffith what's one one of the most
interesting thing about Frank is that
he's not only a stellar academic and a a
very interesting new field but he's also
a very successful entrepreneur so prior
to starting his academic career um about
seven years ago he was actually running
and selling a content-based image
retrieval company called TW fish to Time
Warner and he was serving as the CEO of
interfolio so he started his career
working at the Cornell Theory Center and
subsequently at the Lawrence Berkeley
National
Laboratory when Frank's not working on
probabalistic programming these days
um he uh he placed the ukula and the
trumpet I wonder if we get some of that
to see today
um one of the things with Frank is he
he's really uh he's really uh the nips
conference is it's really quite a an
unfortunate conference for him he's he's
throwing a bit of bad luck in recent
years so last year he knocked himself
out for almost all the conference by
food poisoning and this year when he
traveled he perforated his eardrum so if
you'd like to understand him when you
walk up to the microphones later you
really need to speak up loud so without
further Ado let's welcome
Frank
thank you
Ralph can everybody hear me
okay I apologize in advance uh Ralph is
absolutely correct nips is notoriously
bad for me healthwise I think out of the
10 or 15 years I've been coming to nips
I've uh lost my voice twice and been
unable to talk talk to anybody at the
conference food poisoning once and this
time uh uh I have a sleep slap cheek
which I got from my kid at nursery and
I've never had it because I'm American
and it's just absolutely terrible and
I've lost all of the hearing in my left
ear and I've got about 25% Hearing in
this year and everything I I I'm going
to say I hear reverberating in my head
so this is going to be terrible uh for
me uh probably for you too
uh and I would hope that beyond all that
if I can get through the this first of
all I apologize for coughing and making
all sorts of terrible noises I have my
my tissues here um I hope that uh my
health issues don't uh get in the way of
of uh of me expressing my excitement
about problemistic programming and and
uh uh how cool I think it is and how how
important I think it will be for the
future and evolution of of of machine
learning so
uh without further Ado uh my objectives
for
today are to get you to uh know what
problemistic programming is uh and and
how it's different to normal programming
seems like a reasonable objective uh to
roughly understand how to write a
probabilistic program and have the
resources to get started uh doing so if
you'd like to try to do so uh um I'd
like to give you a sense of where the
field is at and where it's going
uh and problem to programming is is uh
has has been around for longer than than
a lot of us uh recognized uh and because
this is a tutorial uh not only not only
will I talk to you about how to program
in a problemistic programming language
but uh because many of you are machine
learning experts and inference experts
and people that we'd like to have
interact with us on the back end of
problemistic programming system
I'll try to get you to understand at
least one way to Ru your own
state-of-the-art Universal problemistic
programming
system okay so uh what is probabilistic
um I uh I would ordinarily so how how
how many of you come in with prec a
preconceived notion of what problemistic
programming
is okay that's the uh that's the the
problem with nips you all are experts
and everything already uh
so I'll just tell you what I think
probabilistic programming is then so the
field of problemistic programming in my
opinion is is uh centered in in the mix
of machine learning statistics and the
programming languages
communities uh one way to say what uh
Pro programming is about is using
programming languages techniques to
abstract inference algorithms from stat
and machine learning such that they
apply automatically and correctly to the
broadest possible set of modelbased
reasoning applications okay so we're
going to take algorithms and
applications from machine learning we're
going to use some of the theory from
statistics and uh tools like compilers
and and uh source code transformation
and so on and so forth from programming
languages to build systems that help us
do model-based reasoning uh uh
automatically and in models that would
be otherwise very difficult to imagine
doing such reasoning
in in terms of intuition building
intuition about what problemistic
programming is about uh this is my way
of sort of explaining it to people who
don't have a precon conceived notion
about what problemistic programming is
about uh I say in computer science we're
um we're given a program or we write a
program program and it has some sort of
parameters uh and then we compile that
program and we run it and running that
program produces some output okay that's
the standard computer science
Story the statistics story is is pretty
different uh in statistics um in
computer science we don't have the
output we produce the output in
statistics we actually have the output
most of the time so in statistics we
have the output some observations some
data so on and so forth and we make up
some model let's go with a generative
model because we're doing generative
modeling model based reasoning in this
in this uh qu programming context so we
make up some generative model for the
data and it has some variable latent
variables X that are explanatory with
respect to the data in some
way so you know again in computer
science we're given the program and the
parameters and we run it to get the
output and statistics we're given the
data and the and the and the generative
model and we have to do something to
figure out how to turn that process
around and and learn something about the
the variables X that could have given
rise to the to the observations
y so problemistic programming in my in
my view is the computer science way of
doing statistics it's sort of the the
computer science formalization of the
statistics process where uh in place of
the generative model we now have a
program so we're just going to write our
generative models as programs we're
going to that's basically the same thing
uh um the output of the program is going
to be given to us now and those are
going to be our observations so we're
going to we have a generative model we
have a you know whatever that's our
that's our program we run it it
generates observations but we're given
the observations and the task then is to
figure out what what parameters or
distribution of our parameters or
whatever could have given rise to the
observed
output uh and we're going to use the
tools of statistics and machine learning
to do this and we're going to run
inference over this and invert this
process just as we and statistics where
now the representation uh of of the the
the the model is some sort of
programming language construct and the
inference task is is uh rather General
because of the the expressivity of the
of the of the
representation how would you identify a
probabilistic program if you were to see
one on the street well I think Andy
Gordon and colleagues uh defined it
relatively nicely probaby programs are
usual functional imperative programs
with two added constructs uh one and
this is very standard in prog
programming
languages uh Rand in uh gamand whatever
uh the language has to be endowed with
the ability to draw values at random
from distributions so this is completely
standard uh but the the novel feature is
that
uh a probalistic
program has some syntactic
representation of constraints it has the
ability and some semantic uh uh capacity
to constrain or condition the values of
variables in a program via observations
okay so uh problem programming languages
will have constructs syntactic
constructs for both of these the ability
to these random number generators but
also the ability to condition uh program
executions based on uh observations and
that's pretty different different and
actually despite the fact that many many
hands went up I suspect that most of you
will uh it'll take a little while for
that to sort of sink in
uh um what are the goals of problemistic
programming well
uh one goal is to make individual
programmers much more productive by uh
radically decreasing the coding effort
involved in making new models so uh we
all are very happy with our our are
small set of models that work incredibly
well and INF Works uh beautifully in
those models but it's it's always
complicated to to to cram your your your
analysis or your your uh your modeling
problem or what you want to do onto one
of those small formulas and you're
always wanting to build new models and
building new models is complicated and
painful you know you have to read a
paper and you have to write the
generative model and you have to write
the inference procedure to go along with
it and it's buggy and so on and so forth
uh one way to
you what we'd like to do in problem
programming is make that a lot easier
that that model Innovation step in
incredibly easier so this plot shows uh
uh actual reduction in code complexity
in terms of number of lines of code
keeping it pretty honest actually uh and
these are personal experiences from my
own lab there's lots of other labs that
could report the the same kinds of
things uh uh so on the vertical axis we
have lines of Anglican code which is one
of the languages I've been involved in
in developing again this this plot would
hold for almost any other probalistic
programming language uh and on the
bottom here we have uh uh lines of mat
lab and Java code and each of the blue
dots here is an example model some of
which you'll be familiar with some which
you'll be less familiar with on the
bottom left we have collapsed plat and
duray allocation or a durl process
conjugate mixture model and then falling
further further away we have in the
middle an aut aut automa induction model
called the probabilistic deterministic
automa and on top we have the dependent
de slay process mixture of objects model
for object tracking and the hierarchical
bit NE process over in the bottom right
hand
corner and the the the two lines are are
actual uh uh regression lines map
regression lines fit by an Anglican
query that tries to decide whether or
not there's a logarithmic or linear gain
and coding complexity I don't believe
either of the lines it's not that that's
not really the point the point is that
there's actually a real reduction in
number of lines of code and it's about
10 times okay so uh
um uh that's that's a that's a real
savings and where does that come from it
comes from two things one amortising
inference so obviously in all of these
we're not going to have to actually
write inference code to go along with
the model we just write the generative
model and the system provides inference
for us but uh also the expressivity of
the language makes it easier to write
complex models uh and that's a that's a
critical that's a critical critical
feature
um another goal and which is
complimentary to to the last goal is to
uh remove the burden of having to
develop hand you know hand code
inference this is uh you know
complicated buggy painful uh something
that you have to do for every new model
that you want to uh want to write
down and this this we do by specifying a
uh an abstraction layer a an abstraction
boundary a language represent
representation layer in which uh models
can be expressed and inference engines
can be plugged in such that if you write
your model in in that in that
representation language uh you get
inference for free you don't have to
write inference code to go along with it
and there's very importantly uh a uh a
Community Development uh thing at play
here as well which is that when you have
abstraction boundaries in place uh
communities can develop the work above
exclusively working on models and
applications and so on and so forth and
Below inference those of us who work on
inference almost exclusively can work
below this area uh this uh this boundary
and we can feed off of one another and
the field uh of machine learning and
probalistic programming can can advance
much more rapidly
uh in my way of thinking uh the nips
Community has good rep presentation of
both but probably most of the people who
would work on what I would call compiler
optimizations or inference engines are
at nips so this is you know part of the
talk is targeted at you saying look if
you want to write in inference write it
in one of these systems where you can
test it on all sorts of models that have
already been written in the in the
language and for practitioners who are
struggling to to make models for
whatever domain they're working in why
not try out a probalistic programming
language uh the worst that you're going
to get is generic inference that's slow
uh the best that you you're going to get
is an answer you can be done uh so
that's pretty attractive and the last
goal for problem programming and the one
that I'm frankly most excited about is
uh is the development of sufficiently
flexible model specification languages
since you can actually contemplate
writing down the kinds of models that
you uh really always wish you could
write down uh but we're maybe
intimidated by the prospect of having to
notate them mathematically uh so you
didn't uh I I've my own personal
experience with this is is uh is that
I've I we can all dream up crazy awesome
models models over source code
generation and then running the source
code to produce output or scene
descriptions or simulators that we can
we can write to simulate our data but we
don't know how to invert them so on and
so forth let's let's liberate ourselves
and uh and at least make it possible to
write these kinds of models
down and finally the final goal for
problemis programming is that
uh you know when you've got a hammer uh
everything starts looking like a nail
right uh and I think the for those of us
who are working in problemistic
programming that's one of our goals is
to make problemistic programming like
that um and we will have succeeded if
the first thing you do when you're faced
with novel modeling or modeling
implementation task is to open up an
Anglican gorilla reppel or a web people
session or a venture interactive shell
instead of an IPython notebook or matlb
and and and and this is this this is
very telling uh uh in as much as I'm
able to code and do my own modeling and
these sorts of things myself you know I
have gray hair I'm I'm a professor I
don't get to do as many of these things
as I would like to um when I do I Now
default to a problemistic programming
system I don't open Matlab I don't open
iPod python notebook I don't I just use
one of this one of our systems and
that's that's that says something about
where we are now you may not be aware
that we're at that
point so where's the field come from uh
where it's going so on and so forth
uh the field of probity programming has
actually been around for a really long
time uh although it hasn't necessarily
been identified as a field as such and
this this figure shows a reasonably
comprehensive set of languages listed on
the date they first appeared in the
literature and I apologize to anyone who
has a language that they think should be
up there that's that's I did did the
best I
could the key points here are that
researchers in multiple Fields
programming languages on the left
artificial intelligence machine learning
statistics have all independently
repeatedly recognized the importance of
using programming languages formalisms
to uh to to abstract problem in model
specification away from the specific
algorithm used to compute an answer um
and of course it would take many hours
many more than I have uh today to go
through all these languages and what
motivated their design uh and frankly a
historian of science would be much more
well suited to
explaining uh their relationships and
analyzing their relationships and
probably would be less likely to offend
of getting something wrong so uh instead
well I'll point out a couple of of of
notable success stories
and then uh proceed to tell you why I'm
not going to talk about them uh
so
uh how many of you have used
bugs okay this is not a statistics
audience okay how many of you see
St okay awesome
Factory inf.
net okay okay so these aren't raging
success stories any of them not not not
any you know one gotten more than 50
people putting their hands up or
something like that uh but I would I
would go out on a limb and say that uh
if you're using graphical models uh then
you should stop custom coding and use
bugs or Stan instead if you
can and if you're working with Factor
graphs uh you should stop custom coding
and you should invest the time to learn
in for onet or po Factory and just to
throw it out
there figuro another up andc coming
system and language that should probably
go up on the factor graph side of this
this slide but it doesn't have a splashy
logo so I didn't put it up there the
question is why are these success
stories uh um there's there's some
Network effect that's that's for sure
but they all nicely uh address well
understood abstraction boundaries where
inference works and people have lots of
experience writing models so let's look
at them in just a little bit more
detail so bugs is one of their ear is
problemistic programming languages to be
fair it's actually not really a
full-fledged language it's an imperative
model specification language that allows
model uh finite graphical models to be
expressed uh on the top left there's a
simple model expressed in the in a bugs
uh in the bugs modeling language if you
were to write down the corresponding
mathematical denotation of this model it
would be what we call a ga unknown mean
model uh where what we say is X is some
random variable which is normally
distributed with mean a and and
precision B uh I forget it's Precision
or variance doesn't doesn't really
matter standard deviation uh and then
there's some number in of observations Y
which are normally distributed uh given
mean X and some other parameter
C uh great outside of this there's a
there's a data frame which binds the
values of a b c and Y uh and what the
inference engine does is because there
are these language restrictions so I
can't go through the entire grammar for
bugs and point out the the the language
restrictions but you'll just have to to
take it on faith that there are you can
only write bounded Loops you can't in
can't be a random variable and you can't
have an infinite infinite Loop or
infinite recursion here there's no
branching in the language which means
that you can take that model and you can
unfold it directly into a data structure
into a finite graphical model and then
do pattern matching on the on the the
Markov blankets of the nodes in that in
that model to uh Gibbs uh
operators and then run inference on the
resulting graph you just run a Gib
sampler uh great
so we have this this this lovely setup
where we have a language which allows us
to express models is restricted
appropriately such that uh it
corresponds exactly to a particular
model class and that model class happens
to have inference algorithms that work
for that model class great done if
you're working on small graphical models
If This Were A stats audience and when I
asked who used bugs 75% of the people
would have put their hands
up okay
uh following on from that uh Stan of
which many more of you have have raised
your hand when I asked whether or not
you used it is another another uh uh
another success story from the
problemistic programming community and
it's a it's a it's it's it's a real
groundbreaker for for the for the stats
Community it's it's build as a
replacement for bugs with better
inference but um but it's actually much
more interesting and advanced than that
so uh if you note there's a there's a
similar kind of modeling language
although here the the modeling language
is much more expressive uh the model
block here is like the bugs model block
there's a parameters block above it and
there's a a a data block that's that's
that's outside of this as well here in
instead of uh the Gan unknown mean model
this is a uh linear dynamical
system where we have some uh the first X
is normally distributed then then some
number of of x's are normally
distributed with a a linear scaling uh
given the previous x's and then we have
some observations drawn from that uh
from that latent backbone of x's
the modeling language here is is much
more expressive than what you what you
see here it's actually not an imperative
model specification language but it's
actually a procedural description of how
to run this this this model it still has
restrictions bounded loops and a big one
for stand no discrete random variables
but with those two things the the models
that can be induced by running this this
program uh correspond to finite
dimensional differentiable disc
distributions are at least
differentiable with respect to the to
the parameters in the block which means
that you can use much much more advanced
uh inference techniques including
Advanced variance of hamiltoni and Monte
Carlo
where we see our first sort of
programming languages trick show up
where uh you can use reverse mode
automatic differentiation to get the
gradient shown in the upper right hand
corner necessary for uh hamiltoni and
Monte Carlo at the same time as as a Val
valuating that program in a forward pass
the reverse mode uh gives you the the
gradient of that parameter with respect
to its parameters so you can use that
within an hamiltonian Monte Carlo
Loop uh St also has a blackbox variation
inference so on so forth great so here
we have again a lovely modeling language
it has some restrictions the
restrictions make it so that uh
inference of a particular flavor can be
can be
run uh lastly uh
we have Factory and.net figuro maybe um
uh the code Snippets for these languages
are much too long to fit on the slide
but but both are a sophisticated and
scalable model specification language
that that allow finite compositions of
factors and provide generic inference
algorithms for performing inference on
the resulting graph in particular
message passing is shared by the by the
two of
them uh again same story model
specification language allows you to to
to build finite compositions of factors
uh we can run an a lovely inference
algorithms on on on the resulting graphs
uh
great I bring these to to the four just
just to to drive on the point that that
uh problemistic programming tools and
techniques are are actually creeping
into the realm of scalability already so
the today I learned for the youngsters
out there is that when you get matched
on Xbox Live against random players
based on your skill inferred by past
performance it's a huge true skill model
the model down down there in the bottom
left uh solved by inferred onet that
infers yours and everybody else's skill
so that you don't get mercilessly and
immediately walled by Superior players
and I would say if you know hats off to
them infnet is in particular probably
the most scalable of any of the
problemistic programming systems out
there and that it is actually already um
deployed at a at an industrial at an
industrial scale
but I said I was going to point these
out as as success stories and then and
then tell you why I'm not going to talk
about
them uh those languages are all very
well designed for their targeted model
classes and corresponding inference
algorithms uh but the the the
programming language that there is is
very restrictive um in all of those
cases and yet
but and that's really why uh one that's
one of the reasons why people like me
are are continuing to work on new new
programming languages uh so what I
really want is to to be able to write
down my model in in in in any way that I
want I want to completely unrestricted
uh model specification language that
allows open Universe models or infinite
dimensional parameter spaces mixed
variable types uh unfettered access to
existing Library so that I can build
simulators that use renderer or physics
engines or uh
uh whatever else uh and I like to like
it to be easily extensible so that I
don't have to go write special custom
Factor code if I decide to put in a new
operator or uh if I decide to put in a
new distribution I don't have to go in
and change the the the Gib sampling code
so great so we'd like to do this uh this
is going to come at a cost and that is
that inference is going to be harder
definitely because we're not going to be
able to use special purpose inference
algorithms that that that correspond to
restricted modeling languages and by
giving ourselves this this Freedom um
there are going to be lots more ways for
us to shoot ourselves in the
foot
uh
so if we're looking for languages that
satisfy these uh desider that simplifies
the picture that I put up here before
quite a lot the no the languages in the
I guess I don't know what color those
the colors those are over there uh in
the in the blue uh only support uh
bounded recursion uh so fixed uh finite
dimensional parameter spaces which means
that specialized inference algorithms
can be employed but richly expressive
models cannot be expressed and the
languages in the red only support uh
discret random variables which again
limits their appeal when you're looking
for an unfettered language in which to
write and this leaves the the unshaded
region up above populated uh largely by
Machine learning entrance
uh which are not uh fettered in this way
they allow unbounded recursion they
allow mixed variable type so on and so
forth uh they're they're expressive in
ways that the others are not and for
this reason are the systems that I'm
going to focus on and tell you about and
if I allow myself a little bit of of
grandeur I think they're the languages
that are that are going to to to pave
the path towards actually achieving AI
uh because we're going to need to build
tools uh like the neural nut Community
has built for dealing with huge neural
Nets and dealing with uh derivatives and
taking them for you automatically and so
on and so forth we need to do the same
thing for inference and reasoning and
these languages are the kinds of
languages that allow us to write down
any sort of any sort of model and
express uh uh inference over the
same so
uh these languages exist the question is
what are people doing with them uh uh if
you if you set yourself free what kind
of models can you imagine where what
what you
know what what are you going to do what
are you going to go
crazy
uh um let's let's take a look at a
couple of couple of examples uh
uh starting with
this so a couple of years ago uh Vios
and colleagues Vios mana and colleagues
put a paper in I got a paper into nips
called approximate basing image
interpretation using generative
problemistic Graphics programs which was
a real ey eye opener for a lot of
us and in it they post they post vision
for the first time uh sort of not not
for the first time that's been post this
way before but they they they made it
practical to consider Vision as iners
inverse graphics and showed that you
could actually do it in a in an existing
problemistic programming system and one
of the examples that they that they
showed in the paper is is fairly fairly
indicative of the kind of power that we
would expect from these unfettered
problemistic programming languages for
instance they showed how to use a
problemistic programming system to solve
capture so here the latent variable is a
scene description so you can imagine
this is it this is one of these modeling
situations where having the power of a
of a language and libraries and so on
and so forth is really going to be
helpful um you can
imagine uh you can imagine writing a
simulator for capture pretty easily
right pick some unknown number of
letters move them around a little bit
blap them to the screen there's your
generative model OKAY writing that as a
factor graph or a graphical model or
something like that it's going to be
very very difficult but if you have a
piece of source code and a simul
environment it's really easy to write
this this down right what's remarkable
is that you can be given an image in
Venture uh and that the system given
that generative model which is described
as a just a procedure right with you
know picking a random number of things
blatting them down running them through
a simulator so on and so forth the
system is capable of inverting that and
recovering given why the output of the
program the uh the the the random
variables that gave rise to it that
being the settings of the
simulator they also had a road finding
application in this net paper which was
also extremely Illuminating uh but they
were simple in some sense uh but they
came back with a roar this year with a a
paper called picture and in introduced a
new programming language called picture
a problemistic programming language for
scene perception at cvpr this year
where they took it a step further and
actually started started uh doing
inference over really really fairly
complicated uh scenes uh graphic scenes
where say for instance here the latent
variables are uh some sort of mesh and
its deformation the pose and lighting of
a face and the output is that scene
description rendered down to a to a face
now give me a an observed image of a
face and use the problemistic
programming system to invert that uh
transformation and recover the uh
uh the the the latent variables that
that that describe that so X and Y are
shown there under the scene description
and then once you have the the
representation of the of the face uh in
terms of the mes deformation lighting
coloring so on and so forth then you can
play around with it and relight it and
infer different poses and so on and so
forth which is which is cool and they
did this did this with this with pose
estimation and physical objects as well
it was it's pretty nice but
again a powerful example of what you can
do when you have the the power of a a
general purpose in language and a
simulator on your side in terms
of uh writing
models uh other examples of things that
that are difficult to think about uh
modeling outside of outside of the
problemistic programming framework
um I come from uh Andre d mu and no
Goodman among other people um and one of
the things that they're interested in
doing is reasoning about reasoning so a
a typical example of this is the
shelling coordination game where you
have two people that like would like to
meet up but their phones are dead they
can't communicate in any other way uh
say for instance here uh Andreas and
Noah would like to to meet somewhere
they can't talk uh and what they want to
do is is is simulate recursively
mutually simulate each other to to reach
some sort of conclusion about where
they're going to go and so we model we
model Andreas as a program which uh
knows that he wants to go to the pub but
then calls some other procedure which
says Where will Noah go which simulates
Noah and when you simulate Noah Noah
knows that Andreas wants to go to the PB
uh uh and Noah is a nice guy so he'll go
wherever Andreas goes but he could go
somewhere else and so on and so forth
you iterate this process uh to some some
depth and the reasoning process works
out and there's stable points and so on
and so forth but the point is that if
you want to write down something like
this that some sort of cognitive process
and and rooted in some sort of behavior
where you're doing mutually recursive
simulation of of actors in an
environment it's very difficult to think
about how to write this down in any
other way than in some sort of
procedural uh representation or
problemistic programming language
uh another thing thing that uh that I've
been involved in which is a little bit
of a of a mind warper
is is exactly the what I what I said
before thinking about um doing program
induction this is this is work that I
did with EUR perov uh we talked about it
last year at uh at the Abc Workshop
where uh sorry the videos are over I'll
maybe replay them on the upper Le hand
corner here we have a a prior over
programs okay so how do you write a
program what
uh okay a pcfg and after a pcfg if you
want context dependence and you have to
have something else so on and so forth
we're going to write uh s Expressions
we're going to write programs like this
and the the the goal that we had in mind
was to be able to write something like
maraglia or uh or Gamma or something
like that a program that actually itself
knows how to sample from some
distribution so you give us the
distribution here on the right y uh blue
in blue so I'll go back here uh we write
a program which generates source code
yeah uh we run the program that's the
stuff there in in in green running the
program we write a program which itself
generates samples right so that we're
writing a program which is a sampler our
our our observation our Global
observation is the program output we'd
like to we'd like to to test whether or
not the output from the program this y
Tilda up here in the upper right hand
corner um matches the distribution of
interest and if so what we'll report is
the program that did so so here we're
just sampling sampling sampling away
generating programs so on and so forth
and you see on the right hand side here
that
uh we're exploring the space of programs
and eventually find a program that does
a fairly decent job of generating
samples that uh correspond to the
distribution of Interest Okay so we've
learned how to program okay pretty
cool uh and the last example for now
is and I think maybe the most illustr
immediately illustrative example of what
proy programming is is is is about
because it's so visual and compelling is
this notion of constrain stochastic
simulation uh
so again uh Richie Goodman henryan and
and colleagues have have have built
problemistic programming systems so on
and so forth and and some beautiful
example applications of of things that
would be difficult to model or to reason
about outside of this kind of framework
where for instance on the left hand side
they they searched over this spas of of
stable structures so they built a
program that that built structures and
then ran them through a physics
simulator to see whether or not they
fell over right so how do we build
Bridges let's bu let's build let's do
mechanism design okay we're going to
write a program that builds something we
pick some number of blocks we stick them
on top of one another and then we run it
through a physics simulator and observe
whether or not it falls over and we
condition our program on those that
don't fall over and we say give me the
stable structures that's pretty cool
okay that's a different way to do design
and I think that that has profound
potentially profound implications for
engineering and on the on the right hand
side
they they show some really lovely and I
use this example quite a lot uh I think
it's a it's a it's a beautiful example
of of of what propy programming is all
about so if you're if you're
Pixar and you want to put a forest in a
movie and that Forest has Styles and
trees or something like that you don't
go off and and and hire a thousand
Graphics experts to make individual
trees what you do is you um hire one
very good programmer uh and tell that
person to write a stas Sim stochastic
tree simulator right then you run that
program thousand times you have trees
there's your Forest
okay so that's procedural Graphics in in
a
nutshell but what if John Lasser comes
in and says hey I want that tree not to
hit those three gray bars or I want that
tree to to to go around that logo
right so this is exactly what
problemistic programming is about and
visualize very directly so the evolution
of the program is actually the growing
of the tree
and the constraint here is don't hit the
thing right so now we have again a
framework where how do you write down a
model for a tree like this there are
diffusion trees so on and so forth but
but writing down a a model of a physical
tree really the easiest and the simplest
way is to just write it down as a
recursive a recursive simulation uh a
recursive branching procedure and then
if you have directorial constraints or
observations of don't hit this
you can impose them and then ask a
problemistic programming system to
invert that and say give me the trees
that that that didn't hit this stuff
okay so this is a whole new way of doing
procedural graphics and I think it's
going to revolutionize uh revolutionize
uh uh Graphics Film Production so on and
so
forth great
okay thoroughly motivated yeah
lotson
now I can't I can't turn my head away
while I'm coughing that's the that's the
problem but okay sorry if I've been
going in and out I
apologize okay
uh
great so we've got a bunch
of we've got a a bunch of models uh and
we've got a bunch of things that we
would like to do and and hopefully it's
clear that what we what we need when we
when we're contemplating these kinds of
applications is a a fully unfettered uh
model uh uh modeling language and so
what do these look like uh and I'm going
to call this that kind of modeling
language a universal probabilistic
programming uh modeling language just to
just to to clarify I don't mean anything
by it other than uh it's not restrict in
the ways that the other languages we
talked about
are and really I don't mean to to to
play favorites here at all uh there are
lots of interesting languages out there
um Anglican Church Venture web people so
on and so forth uh and they all have
this this unfettered nature I happen to
be more familiar with Anglican so I'm
going to show you Anglican syntax and so
on and so forth but sort of the the way
one writes programs and and how one
introduces constraints and so on and so
forth is shared by all of the modeling
languages of these systems so if you if
you grock what I'm what I'm getting at
in the next you know 10 or 15 slides
then you should be able to go off and
and write your own programs in any of
these languages without too much
trouble
okay ordinarily just so you know at this
point I would say hey are there
questions so on and so forth but with an
audience this large I just have to talk
at you and it's very very uncomfortable
uh but do feel free to interrupt me if
there's a burning question or in
particular if I get something
wrong so
uh syntax so Anglican is a lot like
clure how many of you have programmed in
clure oh as many as Stan that's good
okay um so anglian is a lot like clure
which is a lot like church which is a
lot like lisp syntactically and I'm
sorry for doing this but you're going to
have to look at some some parentheses uh
I'm going to show you some source code
so I'm going to uh uh I'm going to give
you the bare minimum that you need in
order to to read along with me it's not
that painful once you get used to it
it's actually really beautiful uh so
first of all anglian uses in prefix
versus infix notation so if you want to
add two numbers plus is a function the
first thing inside of a parenthesis is
the function that gets called plus one
one you can probably guess what that
does if you want to subtract 10 from two
uh the function minus is applied to the
arguments 10 and three to produce s and
you know comp parentheses parentheses
parentheses uh uh compound expressions
like this uh uh get get get to get get
expressed in this way so you add two 2.1
to 4.3 and then multiply by 10 and then
divide by that that by two uh so in some
sense if you look at that what goes
first is on the inside and then you sort
of percolate out in terms of execution
order
okay
of course uh this is an unfettered
language so it has branching and looping
and recursion and these sorts of things
uh so uh branching it happens with an if
statement so if uh four is less than
five which it is then then the return
value of that expression is one
otherwise it would be two so the return
value of the if expression is one U one
added to three is four okay great we all
can read that no problem
yeah it'll get it'll get complicated
soon
enough uh in clure angen so on and so
forth functions are first class so if
you look at this this is an anonymous
function this this this is kind of
important so let's read this carefully
um so FN is a is a Lambda as an
anonymous function it's a function of
two arguments X and Y uh and what it
does is it multiplies its first argument
X by three and then adds that to Y uh so
if you apply that Anonymous function to
the arguments 10 and 2 then X gets bound
to 10 y gets bound to two uh and uh 3 *
10 + 2 is 32 great okay so that's an
anonymous function and you can pass
functions around and name them they're
just like regular
variables
uh you can use let blocks to to to
establish local binding so you can sort
of rewrite that complicated function
expression like the F like the following
let X be 10 y be 2 and then return the
return value of this let expression is
uh uh 3 * x + plus y as
before okay everybody can read that no
problem all
right
uh angular enclosure support higher
order operations like map and reduce as
well so if we want to apply the function
f of x y = x + 2 y to the to the X
values 1 2 3 and the Y values 10 9 8
then we can map a
function of two variables 2 * y + x over
the the list actually vectors 1 2 3 and
10 9 8 and uh if you you know pairwise
compute that you'll see that it produces
2129 and you can reduce as well and
everybody knows map produce probably
better than I do uh reduce recursively
applies a function to result in the next
element so on and so forth so reduce
plus Z and a list uh does the following
operation it adds zero to one takes the
that one adds it to two and then adds
that so on and so forth and that will uh
evaluate to 10 okay great so that's as
much syntaxes as you need to know so now
you learned cloer and Anglican uh
almost in three slides right
um so uh without further Ado and that's
that's boring let's get to the get to
the the fun stuff let's do one uh one
example program uh we'll do a number of
programs just to see what what anglian
programs look like to give you a sense
of what they're about and then we'll
talk about inference
so let's uh let's take the same bugs
graphical model that we looked at before
and look at what it looks like in in
Anglican so here we have a a thing
called def query uh this is really a a
Model A specification of a conditional
distribution and we're going to call
this gaussian model it's gaussian
unknown mean model and it takes some
parameter data what does it do it says
let X be a sample from a normal
distribution with mean one and and and
standard deviation sare < TK of 5 uh let
Sigma be a constant which is just theun
of two and let us map this function of a
single argument Y which does the
following operation observe
normal with mean X standard deviation
Sigma uh taking value y we'll map that
over the data and then we're going to
predict X
okay so this corresponds to the to the
mathematical notation on the right hand
side x is normally distributed blah blah
blah y given X is normally distributed
like
so let's say we have some data set here
it's let's say 9 and 8 for
instance and what we're what we're what
we're after is the conditional
distribution of this this model
characterized in some way here we're
going to use particle Gibbs and some
number of particles as thousand uh uh
where the data set is plugged in right
so we're going to say x this posterior
distribution is the posterior
distribution of X conditioned on y this
data set and what we'd like to see is
that this thing is normally distributed
with its analytically derivable mean of
7.25 and standard deviation or variance
.91 and what you see when you draw
samples from this posterior distribution
is in fact that is the case Okay
so great what do we have so we have some
language uh it's a full-fledged
No Holds Barred language up here uh uh
for specifying models with constraints
okay so we talked about Randomness so
here we have I should say anglian has
first class distributions as well so we
have distribution objects we have the
ability to sample from them and we have
the ability to introduce constraints via
this this observed function
okay and the semantics of of of the
language are a little bit odd but they
should be relatively straightforward
which is to say that that model
represents the conditional distribution
of x given the data okay great so
running that program is tantamount to
generating samples from the posterior
distribution
okay
uh to be a little bit pedantic uh
everything including the death query but
inside the death query is actually a
different language and that's that is
anglian now we've designed anglian in in
a
actually young V and d tolpin uh uh
radically redesigned anglian since since
the first paper on anglian and it made
it basically in syntactically
indistinguishable from from clure which
is a good thing
uh but it's bear it in mind that the
stuff inside of death query is actually
a different language has different
semantics has the same syntax as closure
so on and so forth and that's that's
often the case say for instance for web
people it's the same thing there's a
different language inside of the query
so on and so forth so everything outside
is closure everything inside is Anglican
so I'm going to skip all of the outside
stuff even though that's how you
actually use and compose distributions
but instead what we're going to do is
just look at how you specify
distributions uh as uh constrained uh
programs and we'll do a couple of
examples just to to uh get you get you
used to how it
looks so a classic example is a bayet
for instance right uh
I I'm sorry I didn't credit the person
who actually drew that B net I stole it
from somebody so if you're here I
apologize
uh but here's a a classic B net let's
see what this looks like so we have uh
let's call this a sprinkler Bas net so
we have cloudy as a sample from Flip
Flip is just a coin flip it's a weighted
coin here it's uniform uh so cloudy is
going to be true or false raining is a
sample from uh a distribution which is
either Flip point8 or flip2 if it's
cloudy if it's cloudy it's flip point8
and you sample from that and reing takes
a value of true or false sprinkler dist
is a distribution which is either Flip
point1 or flip point5 if it's cloudy uh
uh we observe that the sprinkler is is
is is true uh so we set the value true
and then we observe that from the
sprinkler disc that sprinkler is true
what grass dis is a little bit more
complicated but that's just the encoding
of the the the conditional probability
table for for uh W grass which is a
conditional which takes you know ANS and
ores of the of the values of sprinkler
and raining and and produces a different
kind of distribution and we observe that
wet grass uh is true and then we ask to
predict whether it's cloudy raining or
whether or not uh there's the grass is
wet of course the grass is wet because
uh we observe that it's true but this
program specifies the conditional
distribution of uh cloudy and raining uh
given that wet grass and sprinkler are
true okay easy examples we've got a
first hidden marov model we got a bazet
great how about a a hidden Markoff model
okay so this is one hidden Markoff model
Okay so
uh um So Def query hmm great so this is
one one hmm so the initial distribution
is just discreet uniform over three for
instance that could be any piece of code
there you want really transition
distribution is a function which takes a
state and conditionally returns a one of
three different distributions uh uh
discret 01 one so uh uh if you're in the
in the zeroth state you can only
transition to the the first or second
state if you're in the uh first state
you can only transition to the second
state and if you're in the second state
the third state you can only transition
to the to to the third state 0 versus
one uh bounds there's an observation
distribution which is a function of the
state and it's just a normal
distribution with u mean given by the
state ID the numeric ID and we have two
observations y1 is one Y2 is two uh X
not is a sample from the initial
distribution X1 is a sample from the
transition distribution uh given the
value of x not X2 is a sample from the
transition distribution given the value
of X1 so on and so forth um uh we
observe from the observation
distribution given the state at X1 y1
same for Y2 and we ask to predict the
posterior distribution of the three
states the hmm took great
okay uh just for the fun of it obviously
I made this a left to right hmm just
just just just
because this is of course not how uh we
would actually right so this is like
data inlining it's a it's a it's a it's
a gross way of doing this and it's not
uh not how we would actually write write
this um if you have somebody like yan
yan vum I'll show a picture later he's
sitting up here one of my postto this is
how you would write an write an hmm in
in anglian
so this us is all the sort of Glorious
gory uh functionality of the language so
death query hmm defines uh all hidden
Markov models so this takes as
parameters y's the initial distribution
the transition distributions the
observation distributions and then it
predicts with a label X the following so
we reduce uh the function x uh a
function of two arguments over and you
have to look down below to the square
brackets that start sample initial
distribution over a sequence which
starts by sampling from the initial
distribution that's the initialization
of the reduction and we reduce over the
Y's
and this function what it does is it is
it Peaks at the at the it Peaks on the
in the uh in the in the list of xes uh
it gets from uh from the transition
distributions which have been passed in
the distribution for that that state the
transition distribution for that state
samples from it takes that as the value
X then observes uh from the distribution
that you get from the distributions that
have been passed in uh the value Y and
then it adds that on to the state and
what this does is this reduction
produces by consuming every observation
a sequence of of x's and uh it it
predicts them with label X
okay so there's a generic hmm uh and
this now can be composed with lots of
other kinds of things you can have
different distributions for for the
initial distribution and transition
distributions compose them outside
uh outside of angli
okay uh note that if you if you pass
pass in all these parameters there is no
inference code that is that's it maybe I
should just make make that very very
clear that that is the hmm there's no
you don't have to write for turby or
forward backward or bomb Welch or Alpha
Beta mess testing or some product or
whatever that's that's it you run that
you get you get the answer
okay or the distribution over exit as it
were uh anglian supports uh unbounded
recursion and you you might ask why this
is this is uh why this is important um
and we could spend lots and lots of time
on it uh so let's let's first look at
look look at the example and say Here's
the geometric distribution so defy
geometric so let dist be a a coin flip
distribution and samp be here's a new
new language construct a loop construct
which is basically just a recursive
construct so Loop n Zer
uh uh binds the value of n to zero and
then executes the code block below which
is if when you sample from the
distribution if that's true then you
return n otherwise you recur by going
back to the loop but rebinding the value
of n to to to plus
one and what we do after after this
recursion bottoms out is we predict the
value of the sample which is just a
which is just a geometrically dist
distributed quantity okay so uh this is
about as simple as you can get uh uh and
put it on the
slide um it's an interesting point that
that if you have languages that don't
support the being able to write these
kinds of distributions you you've
automatically sort of tied your hands
and made it more difficult a to extend
the language and B to sort of uh uh uh
innovate in terms of the kinds of models
you would like to write down say for and
for instance the the the the church
paper pointed out very elegantly that uh
you need this kind of construct in order
to represent for instance even the most
fundamental Basi and non-parametric
object the uh the dlay process and the
syum and stick breaking Construction so
if you think about what that's what
that's like it's it you know you break
break a unit interval recursively to
infinity and anytime you pick a a label
you have to recur down some unknown
depth um if you don't have this sort of
ability or this sort of freedom in your
language then automatically all of
basian non Prometrics are out you just
can't do them right so um uh I put this
here as an example of of the kind of
Freedom that you need to have in order
to to to write down any kind of model
you would like including Basi and
nonparametrics um but the Basi
nonparametric stuff is is really
complicated to put on the
slide so last um let's look at the look
at the kind of model
uh that
um
uh that's that's a little bit more like
the kinds of example applications that I
that I that I pointed out before so here
we have a a task this is a this is a
program exercise from uh the machine
learning summer school this this summer
where uh we would like to uh do some
sort of constrain stochastic simulation
so here we have a query which we're
going to ask to arrange some number of
bumpers in between this ramp and this
and this Bucket over here uh or box as
it
were so we let bumper positions to be
empty for now and uh we have this
Library function that we're going to
call called create World um which takes
some the the bumper positions creates a
world and then there's a simulator it
happens that this simulator we we just
imported directly so clure anglian
closure Java jvm we can use everything
on on the jvm so jbox 2D is the the
physics simulator from uh Angry Birds we
that is the simulate simulate world so
we're just going to run a physics
simulator here uh until the the end of
the world we're going to collect the
balls up and where they are and then
we're going to ask how many balls made
it into the box and we'll predict the
conditional distribution of the balls
how many are in the box and where the
bumpers are in order to achieve a
particular thing and the goal here will
be some world that puts 20% of the
balls in the box
so what we can do is we can uh use our
open Universe uh unrestricted unfettered
programming language to sample some
number of bump bumpers here Plus on 20
and to say put
those put those
bumpers put those bumpers anywhere we'd
like uh say for instance uniformly uh in
the X Direction between 0 and 10 andus 5
and 14 in the in in the oops the other
way around Y and X directions we sample
some bumper positions and then we run
the simulation with those bumper
positions and we see what happens okay
so now we have a a stochastic world and
a deterministic simulators this is a lot
like like the the vision problem or the
capture problem or the uh
the constrain simulation problem so on
and so
forth where the the positions of the
bumpers are are the the graphical
analoges of the the the leat variables
in the in the in the in the problem
and uh
um obviously the number of them is put
on distributed so on so
forth uh
so if we introduce a constraint here
observing that uh uh there are 20 balls
dropped four of them on average make it
into the end then in fact the system
will automatically infer a set of of
barriers that allow the the exactly that
number of of of balls to make it in so
here we have you know so what what
what's the point um the point is we can
write anything over here on the left
hand side it's a fully fledged modeling
language we can use any sort of Library
we want we can use uh uh any sort of
programming construct we want so on and
so forth we can introduce
constraints and we can ask for the
system to give us the posterior
distribution over executions of the
program that correspond to uh the the
constraints or or satisfy the
constraints and it and it so happens
that the same kind of inference the same
sort of inference techniques that we use
here
correspond to exactly the kind of
inference techniques that that correct
correctly produce the posterior
distribution for the hmm and for Bas
Nets and for graphical models and so on
and so forth so the question is you know
what what do those look like really
okay now I did say that there there is a
a um you know when you give yourself
this Freedom uh you you do open up the
the possibility of of you open up many
many new ways of shooting yourself in
the foot really so if you if you have
this ability you can write down models
that really can't be inverted right so
uh so here's one of my favorite examples
of of a probabilistic program that that
you could write but you ought not uh so
you might ask for the conditional
distribution of strings that map to the
same md5 hash string so here we have a a
length and an md5 string that come in so
that's our observation and a length uh
so we sample from some string generative
model uh and then we observe that uh the
md5 of the string that we just uh
sampled is exactly that of the md5
string that we passed in and we ask for
the the message okay so this is capture
breaking but but it's not going to
happen it's cryptographic right so uh we
can write programs now so with this
increased flexibility means means that
we we've introduced uh additional burden
on the programmer but uh uh my personal
belief is that that's okay we can when
we're writing in C or any of these other
unconstrained languages we write
programs that that seg fault and have
memory leaks and so on and so forth all
the time there there are lots and lots
of different kinds of bugs um here we're
going to have different a whole new kind
of of of a set of bugs where um for
instance you could write programs that
can't be inverted and that's that that
that's Troublesome but but one of the
costs that comes with uh with the
flexibility okay
so hopefully by now uh everybody sort of
has a sense
of
uh uh what the goals of problem listing
programming are where this where where
are the systems have been where we're
going what you get for uh what you get
if you allow unfettered uh uh modeling
languages uh and in fact maybe has a
sense of how one might go about
programing in or what at least
problemistic programs look like in in
one of the languages and sort of can
maybe imagine how they would look in the
others given that it's basically a
program with some constraints and and
and a query is just a posterior
distribution of of the the variables
given the constraints question is how
does inference in problemistic
programming languages or these kind of
universal problemistic programming
languages work okay and this is this is
where we move on
to uh how might you roll your own system
basically
okay so here's the
gist
uh what we want to do is we want to
explore as many traces as possible
basically uh uh
intelligently um where each Trace
contains all the random choices made
during the execution of the generative
model um while we're Computing that
Trace we'll keep track of its goodness
in some sort of way probability has a
side effect and then we'll combine
weighted traces probabilistically
coherently and Report some projection of
the posterior of traces okay that's
that's what we're going to
do so what is a trace
uh in my mind a trace is U kind of like
a a many worlds interpretation of the
program so here's a little program down
here in the bottom but T1 be3 X1 be a
sample from a discret distribution where
you repeat T1 times uh the value one
uh and then if X1 is not equal to one
then we do some other
stuff so let's run this program just
just for a second so T1 is three that's
great so X1 is now going to be a sample
from a discrete distribution uh where we
uh with uh three choices uniformly
weighted so X1 can take values uh 0 1 or
so the first branching point of this
program is this is this sample so the
program will run and it will pick in any
particular execution one value of X1 but
in uh uh multiple executions may choose
different values of X1 as you go uh if
X1 is not equal to one then the program
continues otherwise the program uh uh
halts uh and it we do some deterministic
computation T2 is X1 + 7 and then we
sample another value X2 which is is a
sample from uh up Plus on distributions
centered on on T2 okay so now now the
first branching was finite because we
had a discrete choice of between three
uh three uh three different choices here
now we have accountable choice and of
course if this placon here were were
replaced by Gamma or normal or something
like that we would have an uncountable
branching of the the execution Paths of
the program Okay
so the goal is going to be to to uh
figure out how to to to basically uh
either wiggle these traces or explore
the space of traces uh um in such a way
that we uh excuse
me we compute posterior distribution
over over
there sorry I have to blow my nose
really badly
thank
you
sorry back to it so traces many worlds
execution traces we're going to explore
Traces by either wiggling them or
exploring different paths uh
sequentially and what we're going to do
is we're going to be able to take
averages over the traces in a way that
that that uh
that satisfies all of
the uh in a way that allows us to do uh
statistical
reasoning okay so what's a how do we you
know so I I talked about what the
goodness of a trace is so here we have
the same the same Trace so we have uh uh
the trace evolving but at the very end
here we observe that X2 takes uh value
one with very high probability okay so
we observe a gaussian centered at X 2
taking value
one and that has with very small
variance so what does this do uh it
doesn't affect the trace but it it
colors it in some way it weights the
trace in some sort of way and it says um
actually uh well let's look at it look
at the top right here the trace that
goes through uh and takes value X2 = 1
uh well that's going to be relatively
high probability it's going to be marked
with relatively high probability so the
size of the circle here is how how how
weighted the the the trace is and
correspondingly down below the trace
that has value X2 equals 1 is also has
has higher relative weight to its uh to
its
neighbors more importantly perhaps is is
that that observation affects the entire
weight of the trace right so uh uh
because plon 7 gives uh higher Mass to
one than Plus on 9 does then that single
observation tells us not just that that
the continuation of the trace from the
rightmost point onwards is good but in
fact that the entire upper Trace is is
more likely than than than the lower
Trace
yeah okay so let's be a little bit more
formal
uh what's the trace the trace is a
sequence of inob ations uh in observe
statements uh so here GI is going to be
a distribution fi is going to be the
parameter to the distribution and Yi are
going to be is going to be the observed
quantity so these are these show up as
The observed statements and a sequence
of M samples where f is a distribution
Theta is a a uh a parameter to the
distribution and a sequence of M sampled
values so as you run the program forward
and you encounter these sample
statements you're going to generate
values X from those sample statements uh
and conditioned on these sample
statements the entire computation is
deterministic the trace probability or a
trace probability defined up to a
normalization constant is this uh this
gamma of X which is the joint
distribution of the sampled values and
the
observations uh with the value of the
observations plugged in uh that's that's
the normalization constant and we're
just going to write this as the product
of the observes the G of I so this is
going to be G of I which is the the
probability of the y y i observation
given the parameter byi times uh the
product of all of the sample statements
so
uh uh the product of the the value drawn
XJ given the distribution F and the
parameter
Theta this rather compact notation and I
would say that that one of the things
that the community the problem
programming Community needs is actually
some some help with notation it's very
very difficult to notate what's going on
but I'll I'll try to at least show you
why it's a little bit difficult to
notate what's going on formally and and
super accurately so whenever we write
down uh uh a joint distribution like
this it hides the dependency structure
implied by the program or at least
accessible by the program which is to
say that um what's actually happening is
that all of the distributions G for
instance the uh those I guess are the
observe distributions are functions of
the random choices made up till that
point in the program so in other words
you can change the type even of the OB
observation distribution and the
parameters to the observation
distribution are uh are are functions fi
of the state of the program up until
that uh that observation and same for
the for the sample values so in fact
Theta J is can potentially a a a
function of all of the state that's
accumulated at that point and so to is
the type of the distribution F great so
we try to notate this this way with
these sort of State space model like
notations um where X's are the sequence
of samples uh bold X's are the the
number of x's so X4 is the set of X1 to
X2 X3 X4 um that's the uh the samples
the the four four sample statements Yi
is the first observed statement so on
and so forth
uh uh and the dependency structure is
really everything chaining from the left
the program allows you to to up to sort
of syntactic uh uh uh access variable
access uh allows you to to write fully
connected uh distributions with very
very complex dependency structure but
we're going to use the notation on the
top and and hope that you remember that
in fact what's going on down is is is
this bottom thing and if you're going to
help us with imprints you have to
realize even when you're reading our
papers which are not particularly
clearly notated that that's actually
what we mean when we're when we're
talking about the the dependency
structure in our programs induced by our
programs the inference goal is to is to
produce a posterior over traces which
we'll call Pi which is just the the the
posterior distribution of of the trace
uh given the
observations and we'll uh uh notate uh
that thing uh which is normalized by its
unnormalized Brethren gamma uh and the
the normalization constant which is the
evidence which is just the integral of
gamma over all possible traces so that
integral there is is the integral over
all possible execution Paths of the
program and what we'd like to do is we'd
like to produce samples such that we can
compute Monte Carlo integrals basically
so uh if we have some output from the
program Zed which is some deterministic
function Q of the state of the program
we'd like to be able to um uh I we use Q
to mean question most of the time or
query something like that um we'd like
to be able to approximate uh the the
expectation of that
function against the the posterior as
some weighted set of samples drawn
somehow from the posterior distribution
over traces okay
great so let's quickly do three Bas
algorithms and then see how we uh we
actually Implement these things and make
them run fast so uh three algorithms for
doing this are likelihood waiting uh
Metropolis Hastings and sequential Monte
Carlo uh likelihood waiting is pretty
straightforward uh it's not very
efficient but it's wicked fast uh you
run K independent copies of the program
just simulating from the prior so they
just run the program okay so F here
means just run the program uh K is the
instance of the program um m K is the
the number of of random choices made in
the k run of the program you might have
a different number in different runs of
the program uh our proposal is just to
run the program forward from the prior
ignoring the the the the the
observes uh however as you're running
the program we can accumulate
unnormalized weights as we go along I.E
whatever the system whether we're
running an interpreter or a compiled
version of the program we can run the
program forward and we when we hit an
observe statement we can we can stop and
say hey wait uh We've hit an observe
statement we know what what's observed
we know the parameter Vector at that
point and we know the type of the
distribution so let's just compute a
weight let's compute the likelihood
score as we go along so the weight of
the unnormalized weight of a particular
execution path of the program
wxk is
just
the uh the uh uh unnormalized joint over
the uh the unnormalized target over over
the proposal this proposal is going to
show up uh later later on so when we do
this we run the program forward we can
we can use these in approximate monic
Carlo integration by renormalizing the
weights and approximating the the uh the
Monte Carlo integral by the normalized
weights and uh our test function
evaluated with the the each of the K
independent traces okay
straightforward schematically it looks
something like this uh you run the
program forward blue is basically the
the the deterministic part of the
program running uh you escape out to to
to grab the likelihoods when you hit
observe statements you accumulate those
in a weight uh you compute the output of
the program whatever that happens to be
the predicts in in our cases and you do
this uh K times you get a set of of of K
samples and weights and there you go
okay
so general purpose inference for
problemistic programming uh version
one we know this isn't going to work
particularly well because we're
completely ignoring the data uh so
uh another way that one might think
about um uh exploring the space of
traces is to use Metropolis
Hastings uh and so if we're going to do
this let's just remind ourselves that
the posterior distribution of execution
traces is proportional to the trace
score with the observed values plugged
in great we already have that gamma and
PI from before
uh so let's use Metropolis Hastings uh
let's and let's uh let's make some sort
of modification to the trace move a
trace around uh um and accept or reject
a new trace and wiggle the traces like
this so if we use a standard Metropolis
Hastings rule uh where we have the the
the joint of the of a of a proposed
Trace over the joint of a of our current
trace and the uh not necessarily
symmetric proposal distribution Q for
moving from one one Trace to the next
balancing out in the Hastings uh part of
the Metropolis Hastings ratio all we
need is a proposal so this approach
uh to propy programming uh uh inference
uh first appeared in the church paper in
2008 and subsequently uh in the in a
paper called lightweight interpretations
of implementations of protic programming
languages via uh transformational
compilation where they they came up with
a compiled version of this so the
lightweight Metropolis Hastings proposal
looks something or a lightweight
Metropolis Hastings proposal looks
something like this if you would like to
start at a particular Trace Xs and
propose a transition to a new Trace then
what you can do is you can go into the
trace and pick out one of the MS samples
in the trace uh and propose a local
modification to it change it with some
sort of Kernel Kappa and then continue
the execution of the program onwards uh
uh running the program as as you would
right so with this
proposal uh and quite a lot of
bookkeeping
uh you can compute an acceptance ratio
like so
so with a single side update which which
means sampling from the prior running
the program forward so we're going to
choose we're going to choose a
particular form for our our proposal
Kappa which is to basically just run the
program forward from whatever the the
parameter was in the in the prior Trace
then the MH ratio uh simplifies to
something that you can compute by
tracking side effects as you run the
program so uh so the acceptance ratio is
the is the unnormalized joint of of the
The Proposal um the number of of sample
statements in the original Trace uh the
probability of the original Trace
continuation restarting proposal uh
Trace at the Imp sample the number of
sample statements in the new trace and
probability of proposal Trace
continuation restarting in the trace at
the M sample
so we can compute all of these
quantities by running the program uh uh
over and over and over again tracking
when we make new choices so this is a
very quick quick uh summary of what's
going on here uh so what we do is we run
the program once uh we make all sorts of
random choices and record all the random
choices that we've made then we go in
and we we pick a variable here in the
line shown in red and we say okay we're
going to we're going to change this so
provided that we've remember remembered
all of the random choices that we've
made in the first run of the program we
can run the program again uh uh uh using
those values and then run the program
forward from the point where we make uh
this proposal uh tracking all the
changes as we go and say for
instance when we compute the accept
reject ratio on this on this first pass
we reject the trace uh uh that's fine we
just Reit the first trace and we
continue on in a in a normal Metropolis
Hastings sense proposing variables to
change rerunning the whole program uh
trying to change that value and then
seeing what happens to the remainder of
the trace after you make that change
okay that's the first
uh first
two sequential Monte
Carlo is also uh an option for pro
general purpose probis program inference
so we're going to change notation just
slightly and we're going to uh notate
the little blocks of the of the trace x
ttal 1 to X tt2 as being the sets of
variables in between or before every
observation then we can write down the
joint in an incrementalization form so
gamma of n is now the joint distribution
of all the random choices and observes
up to the uh
the the uh in observe we have an Inc
incrementalization which means that we
can run SMC now so if we if we want
samples from the posterior distribution
of of traces up to
n uh we can note that it's proportional
to the nth observation times the
continuation of the program from uh uh
the N minus one's observation to the n's
observation uh times the the uh the
distribution over the the posterior
distribution over traces up to the N
minus one's observation so we have a
sample based approximation to the
quantity on the right hand side this
posterior distribution over traces up to
the N minus one observation where we
have the weighted sum of of K different
traces where the Delta function here is
a Delta function centered on a
particular set of random choices made up
to the N minus one's observation
uh and Pi n minus one is just this
discrete distribution centered at all
those atoms and weighted by
W then we can sample from uh this uh
this distribution so we can we can
generate samples from the the uh the the
the distribution of Interest Pi n of X1
to 1 to n by sampling from uh uh this
discret distribution by picking X1 X1 n
minus one I.E the the the a a prefix of
the computation uh the ancestor index
there is according to the discret
distribution uh uh uh
uh uh given by the
weights once we've picked an ancestor
once we've picked a a program run up to
this point then we can run the program
forward by simply running by simply
running the program as you would and
then concatenating the uh the the new
choices onto the the prefix of the
program and as we've then hit the next
next observe uh we can compute an
importance weight which is equal to the
observation uh probability of the the
inth observation given the trace up to
that point okay great we renormalize the
weights and go this is standard
sequential Monte
Caro uh uh schematically I think it's a
little bit simpler to think about so uh
in what what we have is uh we run the
program in parallel K times
uh when we hit and observe we
compute some sort of importance weight
uh according to the the observation that
we encounter at that time uh we resample
and continue uh the execution of some
subset of those Pro of those programs uh
often and multiple times so intuitively
we run the program we wait uh and
compute weights and then
continue
when you have sequential Monte Carlo
then then variants like particle markup
chain Monte Carlo become become
available to you as well uh so
sequential mon Carlo in the context of
problemistic programming is really just
iterable sequential mon uh particle
pmcmc particle Mar chain Monte Carlo
really in the context of problemistic
programming is really just itable
SMC uh I'll give you one example of of
this
pimh uh
where if you run uh SMC you can compute
an estimate of the normalization
constant using the weights that you
compute along the way uh and pimh is is
a metropolis Hastings uh algorithm that
accepts the entire new particle set with
probability uh proportional to the ratio
of the weight of the normalization
constant estimate from one set of
samples to the next and you can rerun
SMC over and over and over and over
again and all the particles and all the
runs of the program can be used okay
great so those are that's that's the the
the the the maths in a in a in a
nutshell far too fast but the the basic
idea is is is pretty simple we have a
trace we have a trace probability we
want to run the program forward uh the
observations are the weights on the
traces and we can either wiggle the
program by picking some value and seeing
what happens if we change that value to
the trace and Computing a bunch of of of
stuff that's that's uh that's Metropolis
Hastings or we can do SMC where we run
the program we hit and observe we we
wait and then we basically Fork the
program and and and run the best the
highest weight program so on and so
forth we do this forward and uh the
particle more cup chain mon Carlo
methods basically iterate this SMC so uh
you can read all of that in the papers
there's there's there's there's there's
a there's a bunch of papers out
there but the question is how do we
actually implement this how do we make
this actually run in a system uh so the
first thing we can do is is
uh we can build an interpreter and this
is the the first generation of of of of
problems programming systems that that
came out particularly in this more
expressive family where we track the
side effects and Direct Control flow for
uh for for inference the second
generation which is just coming into to
being now is is a set of compiled
problemistic programm systems where
because you aren't in control of The
Interpreter you can only exert control
over flow from within function calls I.E
sample observe and predicts uh but this
of course is this is this is this makes
things a little bit more complicated but
it's it's lovely because it um leverages
existing infrastructure okay and makes
things fast so
let's let's think about
uh one way to compile or one kind of
problemistic programming language that
and one implementation strategy for
problemistic programming language
problemistic C so this is one of the
languages we worked on you can run SMC
in this you can run particle Gibbs in
this you can run all of the the pmcmc uh
inference methods so problemistic is
standard C plus plus two new directives
observe and predict okay so observe
constraints program execution exactly as
before predict emit sampled values it's
C everything that c can do it's C so uh
here we have an example of a probalistic
c program probalistic do uh you include
probalistic Doh you write a main file
and you run a program this is the same
gaussian unknown mean example as before
we have some uh uh variance a mean a
parameter mu which is normally
distributed and we observe 9 and 8
coming from a normal distribution with
with parameter with mean parameter mu
and and Varan uh variance we predict mu
okay
so uh protic C is is compiled using a
standard compiler standard GCC compiler
and it it performs the same kind of
inference as before and how we do it
looks like
so uh the problemistic see
implementation does does this it
actually runs the program so it's kind
of fun the implementation
is macro rewrite main uh and run it in
parallel multiple times when you you hit
an observe you wait for everything else
to get to the observe and then uh you
compute the importance weights in some
sort of shared memory space and
literally you
fork okay it's kind of fun right so uh
some processes die other processes
continue in multiplicity right so now we
have we have no control over the
execution except that we have the we we
own the implementation for observe which
means that when the program hits observe
we can stop its execution uh wait for
all other executions to stop and then we
can force the program to continue once
or multiple times or stop okay so uh the
rest of a program in a in a in a in a in
a c context is just keep going return
from the function or uh Fork Fork gives
you the ability to explore multiple
Downstream paths right so you can take a
a process and Fork it and it will it
will run multiple
continuations uh independently uh and in
a way that that doesn't cause any sort
of uh uh interference on the in
in on the prefix of the of in the prefix
of the computation IE in the trace
variables that have been established up
to that point
so uh it's sort of a complicated way of
getting around to the point that uh what
we want in order to do inference
efficiently compiled inference in these
programs is access to
continuations uh
so certain languages give you uh give
you uh explicit control over
continuations many do not uh but a
continuation is a function that
encapsulates the rest of the computation
uh there is a programming languages
trick called uh called uh continuation
passing style transformation which
rewrites programs such that no function
ever returns every function takes an
extra argument a function called
continuation it's a standard programming
language technique you can look it up in
a book and it's been used in
problemistic programming systems uh and
is now the basis of of of for instance
web people and and
angli so what does a what does a CPS
transform look like well first we take
regular closure here like so let's let's
look at this for just a second print
line uh plus uh add four to 2 * 3 if we
CPS transform this we're going to uh
need a couple of so okay what what's
happening here so uh times Ampersand is
a new CPS transformed function which is
down here on the bottom which is which
is the original
function times uh and also takes a
continuation and then calls the
continuation with the result plus is the
same thing it's the original function
plus uh takes the two arguments a b and
then calls the continuation with the
result so when we transform the standard
closure up above into the CPS
transformed version uh it it works out
like so so the innermost operation times
23 becomes the first operation so we
pass 23 to times Ampersand and the
function X which is the the this the
first continuation which is what to do
after you uh multiply 2 * 3 and that
function
uh um takes X and calls our CPS
transform version of plus which adds the
value of of four to 2 * 3 and then calls
print line uh with with the result okay
this is a standard kind of kind of
technique uh CPS L explicitly linearizes
execution so if we're going to uh do
something complicated like compute the
square root of uh x^2 plus plus y^2 we
can CPS transform such an operation as
well so we Square X and we call the
continuation with the value and we
Square Y and we call the continuation
with the value and then we add those we
call the continuation uh we take a
square root call the continuation so on
and so forth
okay don't have to get all that it's
very very fast uh uh Anglican uh let's
look at the example here on the upper
upper left hand side so here we have f a
a beta binomial example so flip example
with with outcome with given outcome
says let P be a sample from a uniform
continuous distribution uh on 01 we
observe uh a flip of that coin taking a
particular outcome and we want to
predict the weight on the on the coin so
we have the Anglican program on the left
hand side and we have sort of a a
linearized version on the right hand
side which is which uses let block to
sort of name all the random variables so
Anglin is actually compiled now to to to
Native continuations passing style
closure so if I flip back and forth so
that query is actually just an angle can
is actually just a uh it turns into
effectively just a closure uh function
which takes a particular outcome and a
continuation and First Call call uniform
continuous then calls the continuation
function with the output of that that
that uh that that that function whose
implementation is given here uniform
continuous Ampersand is the CPS uh CPS
distribution Constructor which
constructs a distribution and calls a
continuation with that distribution so
uniform
continuous constructs a distribution
calls the continuation with that
um that function FN dist one calls
sample
uh
uh uh with that distribution and takes
the result and calls another function
with that result uh uh uh uh as its
argument p and that uh constructs a
function and then calls it so on and so
forth that function uh calls flip and
observe and so on so forth so we have a
linearization of the program but the
critical part and this is this is really
the only take them that you really have
to to to get from this is that by doing
this transformation
we have uh made explicit the rest of the
computation yeah so uh so all of these
functions here pointed at by the blue
thing are what to do after you do these
uniform continuous what do you do next
sample what do you do next flip what do
you do next observe what do you do next
so now we have a linearization of the
program great uh we have all of the
Anglican prives and these show up as as
closure functions as well uh
and what we have now is uh the
beginnings of an inference backend
interface where uh sample observe and
predict are functions that we provide
and we can override to to perform
different styles of inference
all with
um uh within all within a a a a fully
compiled uh environment okay
so that's
that so this common framework looks like
this so we have a pure deterministic
computation it's a you know we've we've
done the CPS transformation we've got uh
um Anglican transformed to uh CPS style
closure which then itself is just in
time compiled to the jvm by the the
closure compiler so we everything is
compiled all the way down super fast uh
we control the the function sample
observe predict and terminate and we
control the outer loop and we can call
our function and it's going to start the
computation and when that when that
computation hits a sample statement is
going to pass to us a distribution its
parameters and it's and a continuation
we can do whatever we want to with that
distribution and the parameters and then
call the continuation and and resume the
computation at that point uh same thing
with observe so observe will pass us the
the observation distribution its param
uh the observation value and a
continuation to call and we'll we have
that continuation we can call it and and
go forward predict will will give us the
deterministic uh output of that that's
produced by the program Z and a
continuation called a continuation and
terminate so on and so
forth
so it's a very long winded way of
getting around to saying that basically
uh if you take this approach of
compiling your your into this
representation the CPS representation
then your backends become basically an
outer loop and an implementation of
three functions uh sample which takes a
distribution and embedded within it the
parameters to that distribution and a
continuation does something specific to
the algorithm and then calls the
continuation with the the a sample from
the distribution observe gets a
distribution and the parameters inside
of that uh the value that was observed
from that distribution and a
continuation to call you can do whatever
you want you can print print out a long
weight if you want to but now we have
some sort of uh algorithmic specific
implementation here and you continue
on
uh and predict similarly you get a label
value and a continuation and you just uh
call a
continuation so for instance what is
sequential M Carlo look like in this so
uh we have some sort of outer loop which
I don't show here where you run the
program in in in parallel K times every
time you hit a sample that is the that
is the SMC backend code you call the
continuation sampling from the
distribution great example from the
distribution call and
continuation the code for observe is uh
a little bit too long to stick on a
slide but uh it takes it you know uh it
it blocks and weights as you would
expect for K calls to reach the observe
it computes weights it use the weights
to subselect continuations to call and
then it calls continuations k
uh multiple times so you have access to
the remainder of the computation it's
all compiled and you're going to call
those continuations multiple times and
this is how you're going to get SMC to
explore different branches uh depending
on the weights that you compute and
predict is is is is as
shown
so when you do this uh nice things
happen so we have this unrestricted
programming language anglian uh we do
this programming language technique
transform it into uh some sort of
linearized form where we have control
over continuations we have explicit
control over
continuations what happens is that
basically a very large number of of of
of inference algorithms that can be uh
uh used for pro general purpose
probalistic general purpose Universal
probalistic programming inference can be
uh imp implemented and deployed in this
very fast compiled uh inference backend
framework so for instance in anglian we
have 14 different inference algorithms
already uh a little 14 or more and
basically every one of those inference
algorithms is about 165 lines of code so
um if you're working on inference and
you want to try out implementing an
inference algorithm in a in a in a
system this is maybe not such a bad way
to go so uh I can and you know so we've
got sequential Monte Carlo likelihood
waiting particle Cascade particle Gibs
particle independent Metropolis Hastings
particle Gibs with ancestral sampling
light mate Metropolis Hastings adaptive
variants of them Bas descent Monte Caro
map estimation via simulated healing and
all of these kinds of inference
techniques can fit inside of this this
this
framework which is a a compiled
framework for doing inference in general
purpose Universal general purpose
Universal uh problemistic programming
languages
great
so where do we stand uh the problemistic
programming concept is is pretty well
established the community although it
hasn't necessarily been named as a
community has been around for a long
time there are lots of different
languages uh um different languages have
different restrictions different
restrictions lead to different inference
algorithms if you do the universal
inference if you do the the universal
problemistic programming language you
have all of the
the the the complications of dealing
with a real with with a real programming
languages real programming language
there are inference techniques that work
for uh uh modeling spec model
specification languages that are that
are uh fully featured and and and
general like
that
uh uh and in fact we uh can even um
perform inference uh in in a in a in a
compiled environment so we can we can
actually go fast great so it's well
established we we know what's we we know
what's going on the tool maturity is
rapidly increasing so for the youngsters
out there who are doing homework on
generative modeling or so on and so
forth I would uh go look at Venture and
and try out the the uh you know a
venture Venture interactive shell try
web people try web web church so on and
so forth you can probably do most of
your homework actually in a system now
if you're going to do General general
purpose uh uh generative modeling kinds
of stuff for prototyping models we use
systems all the time now so if you're
going to try out a new model and see how
it works or you want to try uh uh
writing down a model that you can't
quite uh figure out how to do inference
in this is a we're we're ready for that
research definitely we we're we're we're
writing new models all the time now that
are difficult to think about writing
down in any sort of way very much akin
to the kind of example applications that
uh that I put out early in the
talk and some of those some of those
models are are are are pretty
interesting I would say that we are
actually at the point thanks to the sort
of advanced inference methods uh uh or
Advanced compiled inference methods
where at the point where we can actually
handle small real world applications and
you should uh really actually consider
using probabilistic programming systems
to to to help you achieve your your aims
however there are some gotas and there
are some some real uh real stumbling
blocks which is to say that there are
some highly optimized models that you
know and love that don't necessarily
scale all that well in current
problemistic programming systems if
you're going to do LDA I wouldn't do it
in a problemistic programming system if
you're going to do neural Nets I
wouldn't do it in a problemistic
programming system at least not
yet there are some interesting
opportunities to uh uh for for for
future future research not least of
which include writing models in in the
in these languages and in developing new
inference algorithms so on and so
forth on the programming languages side
there's a bunch of people who are trying
to automate what um sort of best
practices from machine learning uh by by
working on program Transformations that
uh simplify or eliminate inference
entirely by moving observers up and out
so uh there's some work by uh Ken Shan's
group in Indiana where you take uh say
for instance this a brly program on the
left hand side and figure out semantics
preserving transformations of the source
code that allow you to to take the
observe uh the observe statement and
move it all the way out of the program
uh meaning that there is actually no
inference left to be done so you have a
beta uh a sample from the beta a flip
with that parameter then we observe an
observation with that likelihood it's
very clear that there's a conjugacy that
can be exploited here so if
we if we do that we should be able to
actually just add the count to the
observation uh to the to the parameters
of the of of the beta as I do on the
right hand side and in fact there are
systems that um that that do these kinds
of Transformations now and more and more
they're able to sort of exploit all the
conjugacies and and even identify some
some uh algorithmic opportunities
for for eliminating uh eliminating
inference I think the most exciting
exciting thing and I I wish that I had a
lot more time uh is uh the de the
development of of data driven and
adaptive proposals for the kinds of
general purpose inference engines that
that are required in uh and the kinds of
problemistic programming language that
I'm talk that that I've talked
about so there's a just a little shout
out for a workshop that will be
happening later this week the blackbox
learning and inference Workshop where we
we talk about this a fair amount in in
the I didn't mention this earlier I I I
I started to just a bit in the picture
example uh the pro the the picture
problemistic programming language seene
perception one of the ways in which they
one of the ways that they were able to
actually get that to work is to is to
use amongst other things um uh neural
networks that map from in their case
only the the observation space but in
the general case the observation space
and the the uh the environment of the
program as it's running to uh
suggestions about how the program should
proceed forward from
there and um if I can talk and you're
you're you're willing to engage with me
uh I would love to to spend a whole
bunch of time talking about this because
I think this is actually really the most
exciting area uh um for problemistic
programming and frankly actually neural
nuts as well
where uh we can sort of think about uh
publicy programs as ways to train neural
Nets to do things that are interpretable
and we can think about neural Nets as
ways to uh compute very powerful
proposals for uh uh general purpose
inference engines uh uh in order to make
inference much much easier than it is
uh and make it tractable to actually
solve all kinds of problems any kind of
problem that you would write down in one
of these Universal Proby programming
languages so uh to conclude uh if you
work on
inference uh and you do it inside of a
problemistic programming system
then anything that you any inference any
inference algorithm you come up with by
virtue of it being hidden behind this
this programming language abstraction
barrier will apply to any of the models
written in that in that uh in that
barrier and as those models get more and
more expressive and make use of of the
facilities of having having a general
purpose language and simulation
environment uh those models will will
will begin to uh approach the kinds of
complexities and expressivity required
to solve the the the most interesting
problems facing us
so working on inference or working on
problemistic programming system working
on language so on and so forth this all
is going to going to Bubble Up and and
and move the the field forward
um uh
quickly uh I have some go-to resources
that I think I should put in front of
you so that you're you're aware of them
if you aren't um there's a fantastic
resource out there for for uh uh writing
your own problemistic programming
language it's dip. org this is the the
Stanford people who put that put this
out there my favorite model repository
short of the Anglican one is Forest db.
org where there's a whole slew of very
very interesting problemistic programs
out there that stretch your imagination
and make you think about what's what's
what's uh
uh doable with a problemistic
programming system the easiest place is
to start given that their browser based
uh languages are webp people.org and
problem on.org and uh the place to find
all of the problemistic programming
literature in one place um although now
the Dan has has moved to Toronto it's
it's not maintained quite as often as it
used to be uh is probabilistic
programming. org which has a list of all
of the all the papers and systems and uh
i' just like to to throw out that if you
want to go someplace to look at sort of
where the field is is going sort of some
of the most advanced ideas in probity
programming then you're then you're then
you're well
uh it would be you should go check out
Venture uh at at at that
link if you're interested in engaging
with anglian at all there's a bunch of
anglian resources out there there the
angli website which has a bunch of help
in general information uh if you want to
learn problemistic programming through
Anglican and Via with Anglican there's a
uh a a tutorial that we put together for
the machine learning summer school this
year which is available uh there which
takes you through in about an hour uh
getting up to speed programming in in in
Anglican if you write applications you
want to use it for your own particular
use there's a there's a a preconfigured
applications environment you pull that
uh from from that from that repo and uh
you'll be ready to go in minutes if
you'd like to look at the core or look
at at inference algorithms angen is is
is open source gplv3 uh you can you can
download it from the uh from from that
link and if you want to get started with
with existing applications there's a
repository of examples that you can also
pull and install and play with so some
final thoughts uh adopting the kinds of
abstraction boundaries that suggested by
propy programming practice will I think
actually move the field of machine
learning forward much faster by making
it easier for inference and modeling
experts to to work together um so I
would I would encourage all of us and I
I'm so frustrated that I'm I feel as as
sickly as I do because I I'm not
exhibiting the kind of excitement that I
that I actually feel about this uh I
think there's there's real power to to
to thinking in this way and to uh using
the the the the tools of programming
languages and abstraction to to Really
uh accelerate um
uh progress in the
field and just to just to make this make
this point because uh uh it's easy to to
lose sight of this Proby programming is
not about magically making inference
easier right we we're not we haven't
changed inference inference is still
hard it still has the same formal
hardness as uh as before but inste it's
possible it's it's it's about making it
possible to denote and work with generic
richly expressive models that would be
unimaginably difficult to work with in
any other way uh and uh we're going to
see in the next few years some very very
interesting models that come out that
are that are expressed in this way
so I owe a great deal of thanks to an
will vendent and and Brooks page who who
are are are here um Yan William is on
the faculty market and Brooks is
graduating and is either looking for a
postc or maybe a faculty position as
well D Tolen is responsible for uh uh
our transition from interpreted to uh
compation um and he's he's already gone
he's gone to PayPal research in in
Israel so you're a little bit late for
him uh some other folks in my lab who
have helped out on the problemistic
programming side quite a lot EUR tuanan
and hyang a collaborator in computer
science and I I owe a great debt to Josh
tenenbom and and bkash mzinga who hosted
me in their laboratory and got me
started on problemistic programming uh
several years ago and I have to
gratefully acknowledge DARPA for funding
not only my lab but a great deal of the
the work in in modern problemistic
programming uh and I'll leave this up uh
and and thank you for your attention uh
thank you for your time um
uh sorry for all the coughing and and
and Illness but uh hopefully you got
something out of this and I look forward
to interacting with you throughout the
remainder of nips thank you very
much